we have a big epidemic with police
officers and deputies shooting dogs I
mean I would bet you that 95% law
enforcement in the street today have
never received this kind of training or
information or do not have it you know I
come from the old school where I started
my police career back in the early 70s
and back then it was taught to us to
neutralize the dog dogs were just
considered property and in society today
it's change in dogs are not just
property they're part of the family and
unfortunately our profession hasn't
caught up to that yet and so that's what
we're working really hard to try to get
this training so that officers and now
can have it know what's going on because
when an officer ends up shooting a dog
it rips right at the fabric of the
community all you have to do is google
police shoots dog or deputy shoots dog
there's a website called the puppy side
that's that's documenting every shooting
that's putting everyone on page this
problem needs to be solved so we talked
to Virtua which is one of the
manufacturers of the virtual training
and said would you be willing to work
with us on this would you be willing to
take the time to to add these scenarios
to your already you know already good
library of situations at law enforcement
handles and they were very receptive of
I can sit in a class and talk to you and
tell you how dogs behave and I can show
you some videos but when you can step in
this 360 environment and you see a dog
coming at you and depending on how you
act is the way the scenario is going to
go there's nothing that you can do any
better than that we need to make sure
that officers understand dog behavior
because if you understand the way that
dog behaves the chances of shooting or
slim to death you can't wait until after
an incident happens and then everybody
rushes out to get the training because
the damage is done and that's why we
took on this challenge because we
realized that law enforcement didn't get
it
so we can teach officers dog behavior
and things that are gonna help them when
they get in these encounters it makes
them at everybody else safe and it keeps
the life of a pet within that family
where it belongs
you
[Music]